recevoir un chèque est une mesure très
populaire imaginé deux en plein
électorale officiellement c'est pour
faire face à la hausse du coût de la vie
à l'inflation qui frappe fort alors
après un premier chèque de 500 dollars
la promesse de second chèque mais
seulement après les élections fait
sourciller l'opposition écoutons
françois legault
l'inflation actuellement est encore plus
élevé que ce qu'on prévoyait dans le
budget qui a été déposé donc ce que j'ai
dit c'est que si la fin de l'année 2022
ont renvoyé un nouveau chèque évidemment
si on est élu
c'était hier mais ça fait jaser beaucoup
quelle est la meilleure façon d'aider
les québécois alors aujourd'hui il y
avait une hausse des taux du taux
directeur de la banque du canada et puis
on a invité ce soir le mener des
finances n'était pas disponible mais on
a aussi invité les trois chefs de
l'opposition pour entendre ce qu'il
ferait tout d'abord dominique anglade
chef du parti libéral demande à bagdad
dont sort je pense que vous êtes à gaspé
alors égalé la bête quelle est la
meilleure façon vous dans votre esprit
la même meilleures mesures pour freiner
l'inflation alors qu'on sait que les
banques centrales ailleurs le bon hausse
des taux d'intérêt
mais évidemment c'est directement dans
la poche des québécois faut savoir que
quand il ya une inflation qui est plus
élevé le gouvernement les moyens de
redonner des mesures phare si vous êtes
par exemple aujourd'hui vous avez acheté
maison puis vous voyez les taux
augmentent et vous avez pris à la gorge
à payer des montants substantiels
on a des mesures pour les premiers
acheteurs pour enlever la taxe de
bienvenue ça c'est une mesure qui est
ciblé parce que notre marché des traites
des balances et d'autres mesures c'est
2000 $ par aînés de plus de 70 ans on
sait que les revenus à cet âge là près
70 ans restent fixes les coûts
augmentent de manière importante donc
leur donner deux mille dollars par année
non imposables ça vient aider justement
directement et ces dépenses sont des
dépenses qui sont souvent essentiels
également il faut penser à des gens qui
on voit leurs enfants dans des services
de garde qui coûte 50 $ 60 dollars par
jour faire en sorte que dès aujourd'hui
ses services de garde la soie à 8 et 70
ça ça vient directement aidé les gens
donc faut trouver des mesures qu'ils
soient qui aide les gens dans leur
quotidien mais vu manière très concrète
c'est pas un chèque de 500 $ à droite
canot après les élections pour acheter
des votes qui vont vraiment qu'ils vont
vraiment changer les choses ce qui va
changer les choses ce sont des mesures
structurantes et qui vont rester dans le
long terme et vous chiffrer le coût de
vos propositions
absolument chacune des mesures et
chiffré on parle de 2 milliards de
dollars lorsqu'il s'agit de du 70 des
genres de 70 ans et plus qui en 2000 $
par année chacune des mesures est
sinistrée une des mesures à faire partie
de la plate forme que nous et que nous
avons donc
absolument elles sont elles sont tout à
fait chez free ces mesures là et je vous
dirai encore une fois il faut qu'on
aille aider les gens nous le logement
enlevez la tvq sur des produits
essentiels c'est un autre volet qui
m'apparaît que ma part importante les
médicaments sans ordonnance aussi ça
être directement les les québécois et
les québécoises dans leur poche juste
une exemple que vous avez donné la taxe
de bienvenue mais en même temps c'est
les municipalités qui encaisse elles se
plaignent déjà d'un problème fiscal
parce que les revenus fonciers sont leur
seule façon la seule façon faire des
financiers leur programme alors font les
comment on les compense comme en ce
moment là on les récompense avec un
transfert complet 100% de 230 millions
de dollars c'est le coût de la mesure
c'est 230 millions de dollars et sont
complètement compensé l'idée là dedans
encore une fois c'est que quand
gouvernement dit qu'il va remettre cette
distinction dollars dans les poches des
contribuables dans les poches des
québécois la réalité c'est qu'il en a
pris 7 cents à cause de l'inflation donc
il ya beaucoup plus de moyens d'aider
que ce que c'est le gouvernement
aujourd'hui est ce que je comprends pas
madame tussauds c'est qu'on n'est pas en
train d'agir sur les éléments qui vont
pouvoir se renouveler qui vont devoir se
répéter encore une fois 2000 $ par aînés
de plus de 70 ans la tvq pour des
produits essentiels to save a été celle
du facilitateur et le nouveau brunswick
ans je suis maintenant est-ce qu'il est
urgent d'agir maintenant selon vous
avant les essais parce que dans le
castel est beau les routes quand même
l'époque du frigo dans le temps avait
d'autres choses dans l'époque de
duplessis là c'est l'échec et si c'est
plus que temps d'agir maintenant moi je
ne comprends pas ce qui t'attend
françois legault on l'a dit et répété en
période de questions c'est maintenant
que les gens ont besoin des vous voyez
les gens les ont de la misère à joindre
les deux bouts vous sentez partout quand
vous allez à l'épicerie bel ébat
s'offre également les banques
alimentaires mais tout le monde souffle
et c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir puis
on nous brandit l'idée d'un chèque de
500 $ pour après l'élection ça n'a aucun
sens c'est maintenant qu'il faut
intervenir merci madame anglade depuis
gaspé c'est moi qui vous remercie merci
au revoir sans voix autour du chef du
parti québécois pour le st pierre
plamondon
st pierre plamondon quelle est pour vous
la meilleure façon de freiner
l'inflation alors que quand même sur têt
se font aux critiques à l'endroit de la
hausse des taux d'intérêt on doit vivre
avec ça nos pôles chouette en gaz
appartient pas comme je réduction au
niveau provincial qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire en effet c'est la banque du canada
qui décide on va probablement avoir
d'autres hausses des taux d'intérêt
prévue dans ce contexte la première faut
aider les gens lorsqu'ils en ont besoin
donc je répète mon aussi qu' on devrait
pas monnayé de l'aide financière en
échange d'un vote et nous on pense qu'on
devrait cibler davantage les ménages à
risque d'une faillite les ménages qui
sont affaiblis sur le plan financier
plutôt que de donner des chèques à tous
les électeurs
pour sa 500 dollars a été donnée à 94
milles québécois donc à moins de
personnes plus de mesures 94 %
exactement ceux dans le besoin sub sont
plus fragiles vis-à-vis toutes ces
hausses de prix ou est-ce que les gens
ça prouverait soffons les sens et nous
on pense qu'on peut pas laisser les
pétrolières faire des profits indécents
ses terres neuves la plus récente
juridiction à s'être doté d'une révision
des prix d'un contrôle des prix avec
leurs équivalents de la régie d'énergie
en grande bretagne on taxe les profits
des pétrolières pour les renvoyer aux
gens mais nous on pense que le 500 $ de
françois legault la dernière fois il est
allé dans la poche des pétrolières
essentiellement il n'a fait que
transiter quelques instants dans la
poche des québécois donc faut agir là
dessus parce que c'est inacceptable faut
également libérer les gens du pétrole en
leur donnant la possibilité d'avoir des
transports collectifs de qualité et
accès aux voitures électriques sur le
plan du logement nous ça fait très
longtemps qu'on dit qu'il faut augmenter
l'offre de logement social faut
également agir sur la sorte pas demain
matin par écran non mais malheureusement
dans le budget n'y a pas grand chose de
prévu pour l'an prochain dans le budget
de la cac nous on parle d'un rattrapage
important de 5000 logements sociaux par
année en sus du retard accumulé et faut
aussi combattre la spéculation
immobilière et orbi nbi donc nous on
veut une taxe sur les spéculateurs
étrangers pour que les logements soient
pas l'objet de spéculations mais soit
bien utilisé pour les gens
même chose pour les rubis nbi donc là
dessus on peut agir on pourrait rendre
le marché immobilier un peu plus
accessible surtout pour les plus jeunes
qui cherchent à faire un premier rachat
et sur l'épicerie mine de rien que
plusieurs secteurs dans lequel il n'y a
pas de concurrence dans lequel les prix
sont trop élevés on a proposé un bureau
de la concurrence pour surveiller et
pénalisé les compagnies qui trichent les
pétrolières mais surtout également dans
le domaine de l'alimentation souvent on
s'est rendu compte que il ya des prix
que sont fixés trop mais je réitère que
dans les circonstances l'aide elle est
probablement nécessaire mais ce serait
mieux de cibler les ménages dans le
besoin mais surtout c'est pas acceptable
de monnayer de l'aide à des gens qui ont
besoin en échange de leurs votes on
devrait pas tolérer ça dans notre souci
est ce que vous passez vos mesures sont
compétitives avec celles des autres
partis d'opposition ouais je pense que
plus il ya du bon dans tout ce qui est
proposé par les oppositions ce qui est
triste en fait c'est d'avoir un
gouvernement de la cac qui nie la crise
du logement pendant des années et l'on
se retrouve tout le monde et à la gorge
même chose nous on met de la pression
pour que les pétrolières cesse de voler
les gens comme elles le font mais je
pense le mot vol est pas exagéré c'est
l'inaction et l'utilisation de fonds
publics qui finalement vienne transit et
quelques instants dans la poche des gens
mais l'appauvrissement général des
québécoises et des québécois il est de
beaucoup plus que 500 $ et ce bilan la
va falloir le faire et évaluer des
solutions à moyen et long terme et non
pas juste rédigée d'échec constamment
vincent durable 20 secondes le coût des
mesures ne vous levez le coût de vos
mesures ou avait évidemment ça va faire
partie du cadre financier vérifier qu'on
va présenter aux prochaines élections
sans faute paul st pierre plamondon
merci beaucoup au revoir un visa
je parle en fin d'après-midi à gabriel
nadeau-dubois le chef parlementaire de
québec solidaire on l'écouté
bonsoir gabriel nadeau dubois
c'est le sujet sur toutes les lèvres le
coût de la vie l'inflation ont tout
cassé que les banques centrales partout
dans le monde la foi et monsieur legault
nous dit un chèque si on est élu pour la
population qu'est ce que vous proposez
je pense que c'est un manque de sérieux
et un manque dion de la part de françois
legault cette crise de l'inflation c'est
la pire en 30 ans et si elle perdure
dans le temps qu'est ce que va faire
françois legault envoyer des chèques à
chaque deux à chaque trois mois ça ne
tient pas la route aussi mettre en place
des mesures structurantes pour aider les
familles à passer au travers il faut
contrôler le prix des loyers il faut
calmer la spéculation immobilières pour
que les maisons redevienne achetable il
faut augmenter le salaire minimum à 18
dollars de l'heure on a aussi proposé de
doubler le crédit d'impôt à la
solidarité
ce sont quatre propositions qu'on a fait
dans les derniers mois québec solidaire
pour agir de manière structurante de
manière pérenne sur les principaux
postes de dépenses de camille il donner
un répit aux familles qui en ont le plus
besoin au québec elle est bonne idée du
coût de vos propositions parce que le
500 $ en un seul coup ses 3 milliards de
dollars le coût de vos propositions
chacune de ces mesures lors en cours
pour elle est déclinée une après l'autre
augmenter le salaire minimum à 18
dollars ça ne coûte rien à l'état
québécois se sont même des nouveaux
revenus des revenus qu'on peut utiliser
ensuite pour aller aider les très
petites entreprises le secteur agricole
qui pourrait avoir de la difficulté à
transitionner comme savard salaire
minimum à 18 de leurs dollars des
solutions il y en a mais une chose qui
est pas une solution c'est d'envoyer des
chèques comme ça périodiquement ça va
coûter très cher au trésor québécois et
pendant ce temps la bd des entreprises
comme les pétrolières par exemple s'en
mettre plein les poches avec des profits
historiques donc on ne peut pas se
contenter d'envoyer des chutes à
répétition ce une vision à court terme à
courte vue centre penser un peu à la
manière dont on gère les nids-de-poule
au québec on parle ce trou ensuite de
trouver apparaît on repasse le trou une
deuxième fois on ne peut pas affronter
comme ça la pire crise des classes on
qu'on a vécu au québec grâce à la maman
bien des gens qui vous dirait qu'ils ont
une façon de calculer 6 après même nuire
à l'économie par contre les autres
mesures sur certains portables les
chiffres et donc je reviens avec la
question les fameux crédits d'impôt pour
les 60 ans et sans qu'aucun plus l'impôt
le crédit solidarité même au plancher
sur jalle tarifs d'électricité société
qu su par le gouvernement une autre des
mesures qu'on propose c'est un moratoire
sur les hausses de loyer un gel
temporaire de loyer ce ça coûte pas un
seul sou à l'état québécois en ce moment
là les loyers explosent partout au
québec les coûts explosent aux séances
et l'inflation qui explose exact la
question c'est sur quoi le gouvernement
peut agir mais on nationalise rappaz le
steak haché on n'imposera pas un pli
plafond sur le prêt d'honneur il ya des
choses que le gouvernement ne peut pas
contrôler donc faut se concentrer sur ce
que l'état québécois peut contrôler les
loyers ça en fait partie on pourrait
mieux réglementer les loyers au québec
pour éviter les hausses abusives et
s'assurer que les gens ne donnent pas 25
30 40 50% de leurs revenus chaque mois
alors logement cil beaucoup trop et ça
appauvrit pas seulement les gens les
plus démunis s'appauvrit même dorénavant
la classe moyenne au québec des prix de
logements qui augmente aussi rapidement
très bien dans la masse et parlait à vos
côtés je pense y est remisé on parle
beaucoup de fierté mais pas de la crise
du logement être est ce que
c'est un piège dans un mois je pense
qu'ils devraient nous rend fiers au
québec au québec de justice sociale un
québec où on diminue l'écart entre les
riches et les pauvres québec où des gens
qui travaillent à temps plein ne font
pas la file dans les banques
alimentaires pour s'alimenter moi ça me
rendrait fiers de vivre dans un québec
comme ça c'est ça le québec qu'on essaie
de construire toute l'équipe qui
m'excite merci guy nadeau dubois bercy
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit